all right i just want to welcome
everybody this morning to the audit and
risk committee meeting
um
and um i'd like to start with apologies
please
um dan
has anyone heard from sandra
also would
just leave that for now show her she
might have arrived soon
all right are there any conflicts of
interest
oh that's all right
thank you
ansel
seconded so okay stan thank you kirsten
right no so now conflicts of interest
are there any conflicts of mistress
sorry
all in favor aye
oh sorry that's a bad start isn't it i'm
still in
birthday mode
i left my phone at home
i reckon it was done
all right
um
no conflicts of interest and
confirmation of minutes please who would
like to thank you
thank you kirsten
all those in favor of minutes being
correct please say hi
that's great are there any questions or
matters arising from the minutes
no none so that's fine
deputations presentations
none of those so that's fine so now
we're up to the reports but um paul's
not quite here
so shall we go
marie's just gone
out
oh that's cool thank you
good morning
sandra and welcome
so we're just um
uh
number five one financial book paul's
not quite here maria's here but she's
just disappeared for a moment
is she
marie
how are you paul's not just here at the
moment so
well maybe we'll we'll do 5.2 and we'll
welcome you to the table and
get your report on the recommendation on
the sefton community library thank you
marie
thank you madame chair this um this one
probably needs no introduction
because um the committee has
generously given rates remissions to
this group
on earlier occasions and
thus still working through
the process to
be able to sell the property
and
then put the funding towards the
repairs to the community hall at sifton
there's been progress since the last
meetings and
the property is now in the name of the
new trustees
and they're working with the crown law
office to um
to get
the limitation to the title lifted so
that they can sell it
so we're requesting a rates remission of
649.54
um are there any questions to marie on
this
thank you kirsten
thank you neville
uh would you like to comment just very
quickly saying that it's it's a timing
issue and i know that staff have been
handling this all the way through and
it's
just taking that little bit longer so
i'm happy to support the report
thank you
um so i'll put the recommendation so all
those in favor please say aye
against
carried thank you marie thank you so um
while you're there should we just
proceed on to a 5.3
um
before we go to paul would that be right
well we've got you at the seat
um
so
if you'd like to comment on this so this
is a
new credit control and debt recovery
policy
and the purpose of it really is to
have in one place some guidance for
staff on uh if they're given credit on
behalf of the council
and
it could be details like making sure
you've got enough information on
invoices
getting
back to customers if they've got
questions or any disputes over accounts
and hopefully having processes that get
the money in as quickly and as
efficiently as we can
the other part of it is
making our
dealers available aware
that
these are our processes and
you know
if you don't pay on time yeah you do
have the opportunity to
ask us or dispute something but we will
be following collection proceedings and
these are some of the actions that we
could take to recover the money
right all right any questions of marie
please paul
have we got
many people owing the council
money and i'm not talking about rates at
the moment on other things at the moment
um
it's outstanding the dentist ledger is
really good at the moment um
and it can vary all you need is one big
resource consent account that's disputed
and that can blow out but
at the moment it is looking really good
we find that
staff are becoming more aware of the
need to get onto things early and
we're also probably a bit more
discerning about who we give
credit to
obviously there's cases where we have no
choice you know if somebody damages
infrastructure or runs into a polar or a
bridge then yeah all of a sudden you've
got
a data that you might not um otherwise
have given credit to
but yeah no the accounts are looking
really good thank you
i did a training analysis just only last
week
um
of the 30 60 in over 90 days and it's
all trending downwards over the last
three years so it's looking and the
reason i did that was because i was a
bit worried about
covert and the effects on debt but a lot
of the efforts from the staff to
actually get people on regular payments
have had a big impact les murray said
it's the
the large ones like the reasons consents
which sit with developers and they can
take some time to to go through the
approval process to 224c
and payment they sit there for a while
thank you
any other questions
well we have a recommendation here would
anybody like to move that we accept the
recommendation thank you paul
seconder
thank you neville
would you like to speak on to that thank
you yeah no i think it's all under
control and um good report thank you
thank you just um one little thing thank
you uh councillor barnett there's a
spelling make mistake that will correct
on 3.5 disputes we've spelt incorrectly
it's gone past so many eyes
well done
thank you
all right thank you for that
okay so um
all those in favor of accepting this
recommendation please say i against
carried thank you
no um we might thank you marie for your
attendance and we could welcome paul
would you like to come and give us your
financial report
for the period ended 30th of june 2021
welcome
well last week we were all practicing
our greetings and stuff in a week it was
good
um yeah so the
report for the
financial report for the end of uh june
22 21
the preliminary surplus
was 33.1 million against a budget of
23.4
there's an explanation of the
reasons for that variance
in 4.2 of the report
at the end of the year the debt was at
100 external debt was at 170 million
which was an increase of 10 million from
the previous year
but below the budget of 182 million
one other item on point uh wrote about
in the
report is that we were
uh talking about the um audit um
and that what it were had some um
there was a possibility of
the order
being prolonged um at the moment the
audit's well underway
they've been providing
a lot of staff so we're really positive
that that will
still meet its
uh time table
um
i'll just assume there's reports read
and are there any questions
neville
think about it
paul just around that audit and the
timing
i find it rather ironic that um
audit can be late but um we can't do
anything late for audit um it's rather
ironic that you can do that um in the
future and this one looks looks as
though you may get there and the advice
you've given us
in the future what plans have we got or
what difference does it make if indeed
this continues certainly through covert
and things that have happened they've
indicated on more than one occasion that
they could be late with their audits
what have we got in place that
covers us from our end because they're
highly critical of us if we're late if
anything what do we got from aaron that
if they're running late what are the
consequences to us and what have we got
in place to
make sure that we've covered comms all
those sorts of things on
if that happens
so the audit have told us that they have
a statutory agreement or it's pastoral
statute that they can
have late audits to the end of december
and that goes right through to 2023
so they're expecting another year of
this
the impact on us is that we don't get
confirmation of the annual report before
we go into the
annual plan round and so for councils
that are under
uh debate around their asset values or
anything like that it can be quite
critical for them because they don't
start off a confirmed base where it's
been audited for us i think we are in a
good pretty good position
we're we're forecasting off
pretty good information
recently
valued
all of our orders have been clear we
haven't had any
areas where we've
been
you know qualified in any way so
we just need to keep on um
performing really and making sure it's
available for audit and
uh
and making sure that you know when
they're ready to audit it it's available
for them and just make sure that we take
all the work out of it so
audit new zealand have said that our
work papers are one of the best around
and we're the first that do an online
audit now so they've got a new system
where we upload all the information into
their system and they effectively do
most of the audit online
and so when they get staffed that are
free or they get staff that have come in
new into the audit and they have to
we we train auditors
and
they use us as a good training ground so
it works it's a it's a win-win for us
but
um because we're a growth council
they've probably looked at us and said
okay we better order them first as well
um some of the other councils that
aren't growing i usually push down the
line a bit or a lot of the ccos which
have low turnover
and aren't as critical
to the new zealand economy as such um
because of the turnover they'll push
down
the line a bit too yeah in a practical
sense because of uh level two they've
been doing a lot of the work remotely
and they've even had auditors who are in
hamilton
coming and essentially working remotely
from hamilton
there's definitely a shortage of
resource and auditors are one of them um
the whole if you go right across the
whole uh local government
profession
there's shortages right across and
it's a big bit of a big worry you know
particularly with engineering with um
such big programs out there uh this
competition with private and local
government
[Music]
thank you and thank you um sandra you
have a question
i note on page
19 of the agenda when you talk about
it's in one of those tables with key
items at the bottom that we've got
um
[Music]
we had
26 020
um rateable properties
um in the annual plan but the actual is
26 362. so we've got
340 odd
um
more rateable properties than we
we had in our annual plan
and therefore favorable variance
how can we
we're out by 340
properties first question
um the second one on the same page
the dividends the special dividend
received that we didn't budget for of
252 000 what's that
so
the
the number of properties when
i suppose it's uh
it relates to the timing of we always
have to have our annual plan adopted
before the end of the year and so we can
never get the exact number of properties
we're going to have
um we tend to
try and keep
not
we do that estimate um when we do the
draft and we um unless it's really out
we tend to try and stick with the draft
numbers so we're not
messing with the calculations too much
because that's quite considerable
considering we we have you know what is
that
500 600 was considered and consents for
new builds during the year so this is
more than half of that yeah um to put it
into
context
we're limited to the medium to high
growth that
uh stats new zealand
we put ourselves in that
and on average that's supposed to be 480
properties per annum over a 10-year
period
and so when we put those numbers through
the plans
and if you remember when we set this
plan
housing wasn't really moving that well
and it just suddenly took off
what happens is we do our best it's a
guesstimate of how much we get round
year end and if we get it wrong one year
and wrong the next year it can make
quite a bit of an impact
and so that's what you're seeing coming
through like this year i think we're on
track to do somewhere in the mid 700s
that's well above our 10-year average
and so
we'll be projecting
into our annual plan this year a similar
sort of a number regardless of where we
sit with the medium to high
new zealand stat projection
we have to sit within that over the 10
years so as we get out towards the 10
years we start lowering that down again
and it's one of the areas which
we've signaled with the planning our
planning area
and it's the same probably across a
number of canberra councils is
are we sitting in the medium to high are
we sitting in
the high
more of the higher end of the step
projections
yes
here ending june for the previous year
and don't we really look at even though
you're saying it's over a ten year
we revisit this every um
three years significantly
and every
every year
so what you know it just struck me that
340 properties out which is sort of more
than
half
well it's well over half the estimate
you you're saying you put in if you're
putting in 400 odd
um shouldn't we well
it just means
in my reading that we are going to have
a favorable
variance because of the
increased number of ratable properties
during the year for the entire stretch
of this
um
this current year well the new this new
year when we get the um the september
quarter we'll be in the
presumably in the same if not
more increased
yep that's that's correct have variance
this year as well because we if if you
look at the annual sorry the ltp and 218
we're predicting uh 480 properties a
year
we went back and had another look at it
and they're still predicting 480
properties per annum over the 10 years
so over 20 years we're projecting 480
properties but every so often we have
spikes like after the earthquakes we had
a growth of about 11.8
and so that's what we're seeing we're
seeing the front the front end of those
first three years much higher and and
every time we go back and ask
the projections are still the same so at
some stage over the next
nine years we're going to see a big dip
in the amount of properties that come in
that have been built in the district now
you'll have different views on that but
that's the data that we project off and
predict from and
at the moment
uh
you know if you look at a lot of the
growth that's coming into the district
and
we stand to be corrected but a lot of it
is uh immigration growth that's coming
in it's not growth within or that it has
changed a little bit in the last couple
years
i think
so we'll come back with council to
council with the annual clan this round
and we'll present those numbers again
based on the recent review
uh just to see what that looks like
but at this stage we're still set
to do 480 properties per annum
on based on the forecasts that have been
provided through the planning area
so effectively this says
this is over in a is this over and above
so the 430
eur is embedded in the budget
and we have achieved another 340 above
that so in fact for that year we were
close to 800. that's right we did an
adjustment for each of that 480 number
years it's been huge so this year i
think as you see i think we're on track
to do about in the mid 700s
and
i don't i i look if you ask me i'd say
it'll be the same next year so we'll be
making sure that fronting numbers high
but because we are limited to
where we can go with the growth in the
district at some stage
um i'm being told it's going to reduce
at some stage now that's
we have to forecast off something
and we have the ability every three
years to adjust that but
within each annual year
um we'll you know
have a
an estimate on what that looks like
but we'll have to bring that back to the
council
and um
as i said we've
already put that under a review
for this annual queen thank you and the
dividend the special dividend of 252 000
not budgeted what was that
uh that's from translation
okay um and uh yeah so uh
so they declare their dividends um
uh they decide how they uh they make
that decision we can't control that and
we just we um
uh
we estimate on uh past years what
dividends we've received we usually
receive only the two
uh
a uh that gives us an interim one and
then a final one
and we've uh
being accountants we do go a bit
conservatively but um yeah there was an
extra dividend that we normally don't
get that they declared okay there's
another question i have um which talks
about
the investment properties um two land
assets and it's an unfavorable variance
on the mixed business use
area requiring remediation works and i
couldn't for the life of me think of
what the two
land assets sorry so this is the read
zone area assets and
i'm the same as
you councillor stuart we challenged that
revaluation quite hard
we went back twice with um information
that suggested not to drop it
but the valuation the valuer said it's
um
it's got to do of the
the land use in the area
and how it's
um currently
if there's other developments that
happen in that area you could see that
we've been re-valued back up again but
at this stage
he doesn't have that
information to value it much more than
effectively a little bit greater than
what we would
value our reserves and so that's why you
see a it's a paper number it's not a
cash number
a land i kept on thinking that there is
there was actually builders for some
reason when i was reading it
must have been dark but um
so is that the
red zone itself yes why are there two is
it two areas they've separated the areas
off
um
it's um
counted as sorry i'm looking at page 28
28 at the
bottom i'm looking at which page yeah i
think they were uh they were combined
into
uh basically uh two big parcels
all the all the
separate titles before north east and
wherever
whatever we've got
oh uh
i couldn't tell you exactly how that
yeah well we could we could get that
information and send it around if you
would like well that's clear for some
reason last night i was thinking there
were buildings that we had
thank you thank you sandra paul you had
a question
yeah i've got two questions um 4.5
refusing cycling recycling
0.7 million over budget
more residents have joined the three
bins program which increased disposal
cost of landfill
i understand
that
the weights were taken into
consideration
when the contract select with the bins
because it was actually bought up they
had to make sure we had the weights
right so
i understand
half of it as
recycling i also understand there's a
bit of allowance made for
some contamination as well so
how we got
0.7 million over budget
when
um
the more people on it
on the
rubbish scheme
they actually better it off should be
for council rather than the worse off
uh yeah so this this point is looking at
the expenditure side only so if you look
at the revenue side there's also an
increase there
so if you look at those two together
i think that's what you're saying is
that there should be a net
net difference which is small so if you
also looked at the revenue there's also
been an increase in revenue
so this this note is only talking about
the expenditure side of it it's
but it's saying it's a um over budget
surely
so so actually in actual fact what we're
saying we're not 0.7 million over budget
we're
in budget then if there's a
um
yeah so both the revenue and the
expenditure over budget and the net
effect is is um smaller than just you
know the
that yeah so maybe we should put a
wee note on that if that's the case so
people understand it
so what you're saying is they contra out
each other yeah
um i think if i can find the right page
reference for you
um
thanks jeff yeah so if you look at page
uh you'll see that um
the refusing recycling
uh you'll see that both the revenue and
the expense are over
for
um
and the net position is better than the
budget
so probably what you're saying is that
your budget
but then with growth that's what has
caused this to happen in both ways would
that be correct yep
thank you
you happy with that paul
i think it's probably best to look at
page 43 and if you look at the operating
surplus deficit we had an annual plan
budget of a surplus of
operating of thirty thousand we actually
did four hundred twenty six thousand
surplus so we actually had a much
improved position after revenue was
accounted for
that's more than covering the costs yeah
that's kind of and the second question
was actually with the property so i
presume the property be the same
scenario as that as well yeah we're in a
we're in a growth situation and and um
it's a bit like i guess the um
the resource consents for building
where in a growth rate you budget but
then
um the requirements outgrow the the
budget and that's what happens with
growth isn't it yeah um with the
actually with the
with the consents um if you recall when
we set the budget this year we
we actually reduced it from the draft
um because of the covert thinking that
um it would be much production
but um
and i think we reduced it around
900 000 between uh bcs and rcs
and over uh combined we were two million
over the lower budget so we would have
been a millionaire
anyhow in here yeah yeah so
and everyone was everyone was
everybody's been under pressure yeah at
that point everyone wasn't really
uh sure how to do what the effect of the
covered lockdowns would be over the next
year i know
it's hard it's tough
all right um neville you have a question
very quickly back to what sandra was
talking about with the red zone
um
my just a bit of clarification really my
understanding is that
that all the red zone came across
as rural and free simple
so there's actually two areas that's
what the two are about is that correct
ones one's rural ones
will feed simple with all the rest so
that's why there's the two-way split in
there
it's not g that's my look i mean you'll
clarify but that's my understanding on
just whether that's right or not
um sorry which page are you referring to
well it's back on
two of you because there was two there
were two numbers there yeah
yeah one's rural ones
so are there any more questions or any
more queries
do you want to comment any further on it
paul
happy well i'd like to move
that we um accept this recommendation of
the financial report
do i have a second to please
sandra second that's one
um i just like to say
in moving this recommendation to thank
paul and jeff and the team for
an amazing job i know because i know
last year getting everything really
under pressure just before christmas was
huge and i could see the stress
on your face so much and i felt for you
um but you did an amazing job and you'd
still do an amazing job and we
appreciate
everything that you do you keep us in
good heart and i just want to say it's
very pleasing to note and i think it's
part of our growth is that we also have
an
increase in our income over budget
and our debt levels are lower
than budget so then forecasted so that's
really a good trend
and well done in good management so i
thank you for that
so i'd like to move
all those in favor please say hi
alexander you'd like to say something
thank you
um i endorse your comments madam chair
i just would like to ask colleagues in
and this is you know there's
a ton of information in here that is
always some great read
um
and questions come of it um i just
wondered about the value of the graphs
especially those linear those line ones
which are many pages here are they
required to come through because the
commentary is
is um uh you know
significant
valuable and i would
imagine all-encompassing certainly for
me so i just wondered whether this
looking at at the report and its
readability
whether in fact we do need some of these
graphs or are we required to produce
um
these graphs but apart from that um yeah
in a good position i i would be
concerned that our um
our estimate of our rateable properties
is is so far shy but i take the
um which really means that well i was
trying to think if that was the case
how does that roll through to
all our planning for services and what
have you if in fact we are
underestimating the number of ratable
properties coming on stream to to that
degree i mean
you know if it was 80 to 100 but we're
talking
300 plus which is significant so just
leave that but um yeah no
always an interesting report thank you
never you'd like to comment thank you
yeah look this is a good report and and
things aren't going in the right
direction and you're right man i'm sure
about that
the
properties uh being over that uh
councillor stuart's referring to that's
our problem we're the councillors
we sit whether we go for medium growth
or high growth that's up to us
we have always taken the middle road in
this council on a conservative side that
we look at medium growth i mean we can
the next time this comes up change it to
high growth
but man you've got to look out a bit
when it when it drops the other way
and that's the bit that has always
worried me and why i've i'm not really
what you would call a conservative
person but um i have i have agreed with
jeff that i think that that
and i think that's always been jeff's
recommendation as around that medium
um almost steady as she goes number to
make sure that we're not um
i mean if we if we're on the high growth
and things do stop and i i don't know
whether you heard the news first thing
this morning when they're talking about
interest rates and things that are going
to happen directly after this covert and
the sharp rises that
are being predicted in an interest what
that does if you were stuck on high
growth
um if we were on high growth now
we've basically got a buffer and yes i
accept that it's a big number 300 and
something properties sitting there but
we we actually have a buffer that we can
work with without affecting rates in a
huge manner
and
i think if we were on the high and we
got a short sharp shift on on growth
that we would be
we could put ourselves in a bit of
trouble and we could uh so i actually
think that sticking with the median and
dealing with the if you like overrun if
that's what you want to call it
i think is a much better way to go than
it is to be
right up there at the top and taking a
pretty big fall when and if things do
happen because i think you can rest
assure that at some point it is going to
slow
whether that is in the next five years
whether it's in the next ten or whether
it's next year
um but the things with these things is
that you find out pretty rapidly when it
comes to a bit of a bit of a slow so
i've been comfortable that this council
has gone with the medium growth and
advised our staff that that is
the road we've
wished to take the number itself is not
set by us so
that we just sit the medium high or low
you know that's all we do the number is
set by other people so
we deal with that number if indeed that
numbers that might they might adjust
that for us but for other people that'll
be different so
um i'm i'm pretty comfortable with that
particular asset
aspect of it i think it's i think it's
actually quite a good way to go
um
easier to
but i do
i do take on board that
putting forward for infrastructure and
things like that that there's you know
300 variants but
that's not not uh not such a big deal
for us in in
in the term we can adjust that as we
move forward
any other comments thank you kirsten
well can i just post it a question to um
jeff then
if we are under
estimating growth what impact does it
have on our infrastructure projections
and planning going forward yeah i i
don't think we are underestimating it um
we're forecasting it based on pretty
good planning
we're not forecasting medium we're
forecasting more than medium it's medium
to high and it sits right in the middle
uh what we're experiencing at the moment
is is a surge um
i mean it's a seller's market and
we've seen a big surge in properties now
we have to rely on um
the information that's provided to us
and and have an assumption based around
that and each year we we
look at that number and say is that
about right
um
and
i mean for this year for
the annual plan year we're going into
we certainly wouldn't be putting the
number of 480 in there we would be based
on what's happening at the moment it
would be somewhere around the 700 to 750
property
but based on the medium to high
projections and forecasts
over that period of 10 years
we have no option but to actually take
that growth back down over the 10 years
to an average of 480 i think it might be
100 485 properties new dwellings a year
and so that's the that's the dilemma
we've got
that we're going to review coming into
this annual plan
round and we'll put that specifically in
front of the council
so
we're all comfortable with the figures
that we're
forecasting on
right everybody happy so um i'll put
that to the vote all those in favor of
the financial report
um being
accepted please
against carriage thank you very much
paul for your work
and um
we look forward to continuing on thank
you
sorry
you you do that we i know that um last
year that and uh
with with um covered last year and then
having to get long-term plan and annual
plan everything done before christmas
was a huge
stressful effort and you all did really
well i really really thank them very
much
thank you
thank you nick
um we come to portfolio updates and of
course the first one is audit risk long
term and excellence program which is
myself
so i would like to report
careful now
the annual report is currently being
audited on time
um and there seem to be no issues
arriving to date
i'm part of the project control group
group as well delay in reading of the
budgets um
this year we're going to give
councillors and staff all of january to
give everyone a good rest this year not
like last year where we came back early
we're going to
give staff and counsellors a good rest
and we're going to delay the reading of
the budgets till february
third thing is we're currently reviewing
software and processes for submissions
and to streamline the processes and ask
jeff to clarify what's happening there
please
so the submission accomplished is the
software we currently use to put
submissions through and that software is
no longer being supported as we
understand for any improvements
so leading into the uh annual plan for
this year we just need to we just got a
little project
in place to actually look at the
currents other you know submission
uh software they've got in place and put
a a process around it
the key one which we've been
experiencing issue with is with the
letters and
that part of that is to concentrate on
getting that one right
the other parts of the process seem to
be going okay
we took it on board
during the ltp round that some of the
information that that's brought through
from the submissions like
there's the key areas where there's a
summary of the submission and then
there's this the staff recommendation
the reason for the recommendation and
the reply that's going to go
to the submitter
and we've taken on board that that
information needs to be improved a bit
as well so we're just going through that
exercise
now
so we've got a program in place to try
and complete that by the end of november
so that we're well in uh
front of the
submission play uh
the submission
process that will take place around
march april next year
and just
uh madam chair has just um
presented with there's a proposal going
in front of the pcg to actually extend
uh the reading of the budgets until
february because it's not a ltp year
just to push that out until february so
it gives
elected members and staff the
opportunity over a pretty stressful year
and covert to have that rest over
january january and come back in
february to read those budgets
so uh
yeah
we'll bring the result of that
back to the council but you should see a
bit of an improved process
through the annual
plan any questions kirsten thank you
just just the one that we have closed
that loop from other issues that are
brought to us during that process that
are actually operational service issues
is that loop being closed so that those
issues are then followed up through the
letters that are sent out
yeah so
the other triaging of whether it's a
submission to the plan or whether it's a
real true
service request that can be fixed there
and then yes
so there'll be a little bit of a triage
in front of
that submission going in
making sure that
there's a bit of communication between
the submitter and ourselves as well just
to make sure we've got it right and that
they think it is just a maintenance
thing to be rectified yes could i ask
that the special attention is paid to
the community board submissions because
some of those are long-term issues that
aren't service request bits they are
they get an advice that it is going to
be looked into we've got to make sure
that it is done for community boots
any other questions there
paul
just to weave over tongue and cheek
and the auditors at audit councils are
they the same auditors groups that order
three waters on their
um
facts and figures out supplying councils
no
oh that's good then so that process
hasn't started until
yeah so the order uh the
the
auditor general hasn't been requested to
do any audits over the proposals at this
stage and that was one of the questions
that we did ask them wasn't it yeah
that's right um just to clarify the the
auditors are not
um so the audit new zealand is a it's
almost like a
it's a separate unit
or department to the auditor general
they work independently
and
they they pass that what the
requirements are down each year just as
all at new zealand do that they also
take it out to the
to the market and you you'll get some of
the big four uh auditing councils as
well so i think timaru for instance has
ordered to
buy one of uh
you know a commercial company
and so i understand you know
a
canterbury museum for instance it's
another one there's a lot of entities
that are audited other than audit new
zealand
it's done on a contractual basis and
that's to make sure it's tested and
there's a a you know it's you've got a
standard uh uniform through the country
and pricing is all done the same
all right okay so we'll move on to oh
sorry john you'd like to say and welcome
yeah jeff and i did have a conversation
with the office of the auditor general
and suggested that they may want to have
a look at these numbers on behalf of
parliament but um
i don't think they have the mandate yet
but at some point they should
just keep keep on
keeping on
all right thank you for that um kirsten
we would like to hear about customer
service from you thank you
and to be honest madam chair this covert
has actually caught me on the hot and i
haven't had a chance to catch up with
marie during lockdown so
this month it will be a very quiet
report and just say customer services is
doing their thing really well as usual
thank you
thank you now communications neville
thank you well
very much the same
haven't been really near the building
much but i have been talking to alistair
and um and of course they've been
tied up pretty much with covert um and
um uh district plan still tidying up the
end of the the uh flood um that's you
know the flood stuff that's happening as
well so most of you will probably
receive yes the communication that's
that's gone out so they've been working
pretty heavily on them
on
those things and of course their annual
the report
um
the final comms report is due in
april for april june is due so that's
all but done is my understanding just i
think management it's got to go through
management first before it's um released
so that's where they're at and then
obviously you'll hear from
comms this afternoon you know when we
have a
chat so all
any right of neville
thank you neville
no we just go on to any any other
questions that anyone might have
no
urgent general business
so
we will close the open meeting for now
and we'll move into public excluded and
give the girls time
a couple of minutes to